So anyways,
Pinocchio doesn't know any better and
he's got the egotism of youth and he's
offered the easy way to success,
which is exactly what the Fox tells them
and off they go to see Stromboli.
So this is the song,
I'm not going to read it all.
It's great to be a celebrity and actor's
life for me.
Um,
you sleep till after to you promenade a
big cigar,
you tour the world in a private car,
you dine on chicken and caviar and
actor's life for me.
So it's all this idea of,
of wealth and public exposure and zero
attention whatsoever to anything
regarding responsibility or discipline
or learning.
And so it's a dual attraction,
right?
You get everything we want and you don't
have to do anything.
Jesus.
What a deal.
And so that's what the act or
represents.
It's,
it's a liar.
Fundamentally,
it's someone who's acting out a,
a deception there,
a persona in the union sense.
So the persona is the mask you wear in
public that you might even think you
are,
but you're not.
It's this mask and that's the,
that's the persona.
So the Fox and the cat,
or inviting the puppet to only become a
persona and and that's,
that's see for you,
you start as a persona and then when you
start to investigate the parts of you
that don't really fit in that persona,
that would be the shadow.
Then you start understanding who you
really are and that's shocking because
the persona contains everything roughly
speaking that you think is good.
It may be even that your immediate
culture thinks is good and then the
shadow contains everything that's not
part of that and some of that's really
bad,
but some of it is good,
disguised as bad,
and you can't break out of the persona
and transcended until you incorporate a
lot of what's in the shadow.
And so for example,
if you're an extraordinarily
compassionate person,
let's say 98th percentile will say
you're going to be sacrificing yourself
to other people all the time and there
are people who will find that
extraordinarily endearing and it will be
under some circumstances.
But the problem is is that you will
sacrifice yourself and that's a really
bad attitude to have.
For example,
towards adult males.
It's a great thing for infants,
but for adult males is the wrong
approach,
and so you will get taken advantage of
continually by people who are looking
for someone like you until you grow some
teeth and you'll think,
no,
no.
That's the opposite of compassion.
Being able to bite hard is the opposite
of compassion,
which it is,
and so you'll have that pushed into the
predatory category.
I'm not doing that.
I'm not getting angry.
I don't like conflict.
It's like until you bring that out of
the depths and put it on so you can use
it,
you're going to be in trouble and that's
kind of niches,
idea of the reevaluation of good and
evil,
right?
You have a sense of what's good in a
sense of what isn't with your
conscience,
but it's not very smart.
It's got things in the wrong boxes and a
lot of the things that even nature
itself,
a lot of the things that you accept as
untrammeled goods like compassion,
let's say have a very dark side,
first of all,
and second are not enough to get you
through life.
You need the opposite virtues to and so
you have to develop them and so you get
outside the persona to do that,
but anyways,
Pinocchio was invited to be a false
persona,
to take the gains of celebrity without
having to do anything to be educated.
He's just gonna go right to the top from
right where he is and you know people
are kind of fascinated by that idea.
That's why you watch America's got
talent or the x factor which your shows
I actually love.
By the way you,
you.
You never see narcissism in its pure
forms.
Then you see it when you watch people
who display an absolute lack of talent
and become homicidal.
When someone dares pointed out,
right,
accusatory and homicidal,
instantly it's,
it's really something,
and then now and then you do see one of
these people who's so introverted and so
out of society and have this
unbelievable gift,
which is also something really
remarkable to see and it's no wonder
those things are so popular.
They're psychologically extraordinarily
interesting.